no life is beautiful guys really and you
know a festival is the vegas way to
celebrate that life is beautiful 2022
starts on september 16th and our guy
craig asher neyman is back to tell us
what we can expect when art and culture
takes over downtown las vegas oh yes
it's takeover the best way to describe
it
absolutely it's just a fun weekend yeah
we get to revel in the streets of
downtown i love it i love it art culture
music all everything in one and one
place and you know general admission
tickets are still available yep channel
admission is the only ticket the only
tickets are available so what was the
demand like when you announced the new
lineup and you know the 2022 festival
was coming uh well our pre-sales were
all tremendous and that i think is all
vegas right there buying early our vip
ticket sales were through the roof this
year we just have ga left but i think
you know from a lineup and where we're
looking at things you look at our
headliners i accidentally became a trio
of uk headliners but like arctic monkeys
only playing three shows in america this
year we're the first one right they
haven't played the vegas since 2014 and
life is beautiful you have gorillas back
but they just dropped a new song with
team impala headliner from last year and
their album coming out we're the only
festival this year for them calvin
harris for his festival in america this
year so like top to top to bottom we're
just really thrilled about the lineup
that's amazing and and it's not a hot
ticket just because of the music let's
talk about everything else that is a
part of life is beautiful that what
makes life is beautiful so beautiful
yeah well our art program announced
today and we have some really incredible
artists and installations that are
coming on site leon kerr is amazing uh
neon salt water is going to be fantastic
space object too so really fun
much like see with your eyes as much as
eat with you know you eat with your eyes
type thing so speaking of eating with
food this year new to that is our
pizzeria so we have like nine of the
best pizza chefs in this entire state
three a day 200 pies when they're gone
they're gone the live cooking is next
door to that so we have the cookout back
so it's just really great highlights of
all the best food and drink that we have
in the city that's amazing it's a
melting pot everyone coming together but
what i love about life is beautiful it's
so localized you guys really rep las
vegas why do you choose to do that what
does that mean to you we are a homegrown
festival here in vegas we you know for
the last 10 years everything we can do
to pour into this city and let everybody
else know that coming in from out of
town too like this is to celebrate las
vegas this is what we have to highlight
and we have so much just talent in this
city across the board in every single
category and we're the entertainment
capital of the world we have hospitality
up and down right all over the city so
what better than showcasing all of it to
to everyone both locally as well as
those tourists who are coming in too
absolutely so that's why everyone needs
to see the rising stage rising stars
that's where you have the rising star
excuse me that's where you have people
coming into town but also local artists
performing talk about that aspect yeah
we're really excited about that this
year rising star stage is in its second
year we've doubled up the amount of
locals we had to battle the bands
earlier this year that had over 300
local artists play an online set with
our sessions which was our sponsor for
the stage and out of that we did a
battle the band with 15 of them at the
space with mark chinook and then now six
of them made the festival so we're
really excited about oh
is there someone have you seen a success
story from you know just a local artist
that played at life as beautiful then
just blew up right after that uh we have
a lot of success stories i would say but
if you look at someone like echo who's
played and is touring and continuing to
get bigger and grow from there um i
think from the rising star stage last
year i apologize i'm skipping the artist
but that artist was able to pay off
their student debts oh that's amazing
another artist was able to buy a house
from there so it's like these artists
are really starting to like make strides
and again if one person discovers them
that's a new fan and who knows what can
happen next absolutely so you guys have
to come down life is beautiful it is the
time we wait for here in las vegas
website life is beautiful.com there you
go ken dawson